Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Clickplay Quickfire number 1.
This is a puzzle game.
Clickplay Quickfire
Clickplay Quickfire. Clickplay Quickfire. Clickplay *Thtutpththp*
Clickplay Quickfi- Oh my god. I'm getting worse.
Clickplay Quick....
Oooooh
Clickplay Quickfire
Cwick pway
Oooohhhhhh
Quickfire clickplay Cwoqire
Aaahhhh
Clickplay Quickfire Clickplay
*getting tounge twisted*
Clickplay Quickfir- Ahhh! Come on!
ClickPlay Quickfire ClickPlay Quickfire ClickPlay Quickfire
*deep inhale*
I did it!!!
Okay, now try 10 times in a row.
I challenge anyone at home to be able to say that title 10 times fast.
You can't do it.
But this game is supposed to use your brain to do a lot of fast paced stuff.
And I don't usually like to use my brain.
It's reserved for very special tasks.
Such as the finding food and seducing ladies.
But my brain is challenged enough in my day to day- Oh that sounds bad
I've got a great brain, a huge brain,
the best brain in town.
You ask anybody, they'll say "Who has the best brain? I Do."
Not them... me. I say that. They don't say that. Alright...
Okay.
"Crank It Up"
Ohh...
*giggles*
Oh, that's adorable.
Uh, stingless..... Oh two differences.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Got it!!
I'm a genius.
Hold down and drag to paint larger areas.
Oh its disappearing.
Eh, eh, eh, wait!
Ahhhhhhhhheeeeeee...
Yeah! YEAH! Okay.
I got it. Okay.
So, ooh. Three odds- Oh.
These- yeah.
Got em!
Okay, we're doing good.
Love is in the air. Choose whether the given statement is true or false before the timer runs out
Press a button to start
*game sounds*
Get ready!
Uh, no!
Ehhh.
Ahh, yes!
Yes.
Ehhh. Uh, yes!
Ehhh. Uh, no.
Ehhh.
Ahhh, no.
Okay. Yeah!
Hell yea! This is adorable.
Umm... monster mealtime.
I don't know what to do.
Well that doesn't seem right.
Ohh, okay.
Ahhh, blood.
Ahhh, oil?
That's not right is it?
*gasps*
Oh, no!
Oh, that's right! It's the robo!
Ahhh, you would want kids and YOU need oil.
Oh, I'm an idiot.
Ohh, and you want brains!
Wait, oh. You're on a diet.
Yeah! I think? I have no idea.
Okay so- Oh.
Ahhh, foot.
Aaaaahh, why can't I see thissss?
What is going ooonnn?
I'm not seeing anything different...
Use the cross-eyed technique.
That'll highlight the differences immediately.
I can't.. Oh the tongue.
Okay and..
am I stupid?!
Am- Ohhhh the tree!!
The tree in the background!
Yeaah! Okay, I got this.
Okay. So the trick on those
is you cross your eyes and then the differences
will be like shimmering in your vision.
You cross it so that they're the same image.
Okay. Let's see...
Three mice minus "M"
Three ice. Three ice. Cat.
Ice......Tea?
Ooo! Ice tea!
ICE...TEA.
Yeaah!!! Ice tea!
Oh, I knew that right away. Okay
Oooh... Three odd spinners. Okay.
The guys spinning the wrooooong direction
are you.
You.
Oh man. This is like a IQ test.
I'm not down for this. Okay.
*sing-song voice*
Ayyyyyyy
Shoot all indicated targets.
Don't shoot all the other targets.
*worried yelp*
I don't know... I don't know... Okay.
No. I- Ahhhh! I thought that meant
to- ahhh! "A". The other character...
All right...
Eh. Ah. Eh. Ah. OOoh.
Eh. Ah.
*stammering* Wait wait wuhhh???
Uh...
Uh huh!
Ahhh?
I JUST...
Ohhhh did it say not to shoo- uhhhhg
Okay I got this.
Dooon't shoot- ahhhhhhh
Okay.
I gotcha.
Alright shoooot.
Alright.
aaauuUUGHHHHHHH
God damnit
ooOOOHHHH yeah
Getting it, getting it, getting it, getting it, getting it.
BAM! They're dead.
I did it!I killed them.
Do I win a prize? Am I doing good?
Okay.
Taking a plunge?
Ugh..this-this
Oh, tha-that felt wrong.
Something very wrong about that.
Oh, god not again
Arrg..
Hearrg...
*bad Swedish accent*
Heargin Spergain and Heargin
Got it!
See, the cross eyed technique really works.
Ohhh.
Ah, okay.
*electronic sounding music*
Eh.
*sing-song voice*
OOOOOHHHH!
Ah...Three chipped teeth.
Oh, you... Saw that.
You can't hide you disgustingly
deformed teeth from me.
I'll spot it a mile away.
Whoop...Gotcha! Okay.
Cold hard facts.
Choose to whether the
given statement is
true or false. Okay!
Ah.. NO!
Aaahhh...Yes.
Aaaaaahh... Wrong.
Aaaahhh... Yes.
Ahhh Errgh... Nnnnnnno.
Ennnnh... Yes.
AAAHH! Okay, I'm doing good.
Whole lotta stars.
What are we doin', What are we doin', What are we doin'?
I don't know what we're doing
What a- Wha- What?!?
Ah
OH! How many yellow ones are there?
Okay, that's easy.
Boink!
Got it!
BOINK!
Enh
Boink. Okay.
There we go. I boinked 'em good.
Man, how many of these things are there?
*dinging sounds*
Ah
Ah-ha! Got it.
Okay, the clues.
This is an I.Q. test.
This is literally an I.Q. test.
Okay.
One
Three
So, three- total number of triangles so tha's-
One, two, three, four
Total number of triangles?
five, six, seven, eight.
Eight
One
Three
Zero
Yeah?
No?
Damn it
Oh, sorry. I had it the wrong way around. This is a-
This is a- I had it right I just had it-
I didn't look at the symbols close enough
because that's what I fail upon.
Oh god. Three eyed trio
K- You
You
an-You
Okay.
My God.
How many of these are there?
Fix it good.
Okay.
*game sounds*
Aright.
Ah-Ha! Oh, this is a hard one.
Okay, that's probably fine.
Ohhh no, oooh no, oh noo.
Oh Nooo- Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Ah-da-da-da-da it's Mike Lebowski
Mi-Mike La-ba-Wowski it-it was Mike Lebwowski
*game sounds*
Okay
Ha ha! Okay!
Good god!
OOHHHH!
Hell yeah!
I did it. I won.
With my big brain that I used effectively
and did everything that I needed to do with a brain.
I did it, and now I challenge you guys to beat my score.
That was actually really fun because it was so cute.
I didn't actually think I'd have to literally think so much
I thought it was gonna be
Like..
*chokes on air*
You ever have a hiccup just catch ya off guard like that?
I thought I'd have to be doing more...
Y'know, stupid thinking.
Like an impossible quiz or something like that.
But either way that was a lot of fun.
I'll put a link in the description down below,
and let me know what your
score was at the end of the quiz
Who's smarter than me out there?
So thanks again everybody for watching,
and as always I'll see YOU in the next video.
Buh-Bye!